I get the sense that you like stories
that they kind of push the envelope and
they're a little different but have you
ever written something where you wrote
specifically to be commercial because
you knew it would sell yes
actually I have written I wrote a couple
of scripts specifically to be commercial
but it also strangely enough was pushing
the envelope but but I really wrote it
to be commercial it's a script called
memoirs I'm a virgin I wrote it
because I thought that I did think it
was a great exploration of religion and
sex and the idea of how religion impacts
our sexuality and all this kind of stuff
but I but I thought it would be really
really commercial and it's funny because
at the time it was a little too risque
it was commercial like my my manager
loved it he thought it was really
commercial and this is gonna sound so
weird
it is the script that got me into the
Disney fellowship really this trip but
you know Disney is like a big
conglomerate of like point Avista
pictures and all so it's not just Disney
that's just the name yes so your
question oh so did you did you write
something to be specifically commercial
and how did you feel about going for
that market knowing that you do like
things that are really that exposed a
lot of truths about people that maybe
some of the commercial stuff is they
can't handle that yeah um it's tough it
was tough for me to write something that
was that I thought was just commercial I
when I was in the fellowship I pitched
an idea I've actually pitched three
ideas there were two that I really
wanted to do I should have just pitched
the one that I really wanted to write
but I knew I had to pitch something
commercial so I pitched this idea that I
did not want to write but but I knew was
we commercial and they went for it and
so that is the script that I wrote while
I was in the Disney fellowship for them
it has never seen I've never shown it to
anyone other than them okay I had to
show it to them right but and it's not
like it's the worst script in the world
but I'm very very critical and I don't
think it represents me right I don't
think it represents what I'm about my
voice nothing it was very very
commercial and I was just like yeah I
can't my manager was like this is a
great idea so commercial please show me
that script and I was like no you'll
never see it again
I can't have mine no no so if you're
critical of something that you've done
can you go back and change it or once
you know this is not what I want you
walk away well I can go back and she
actually gave that concept that script
idea to someone else and said you can
put your name on it so you you can tweak
it but you've got to make it better than
just the commercial crap that it is
right now
and if you do that then we can go out
with it otherwise I just can't it's just
I need more it be saying more I needed
to be doing more so so we're not getting
into too many of the details about why
what was it about the story or the
character that you didn't like or I was
that much I created a very stereotypical
commercial script hmm essentially it was
like Robin Hood in the hood so rad but
it was super commercial at the time it
was the kind of movies that probably
they would make or whatever and I was
like but I don't want him I don't want
him to make it terribly bobble I want
him to make it so there was no truth in
it you just fell it was all stereotype
it was all what people they wanted some
little cuz it's bait you know it's
Robin Hood so it's whatever that is but
yeah yeah I did not feel that it was
authentic it wasn't how would I yeah
I couldn't you couldn't yeah I wasn't
true yeah it off it wasn't truthful I'll
just go with that it wasn't truthful it
was just very marketable good commercial
and aside from your agent did other
people say you should you should do this
oh yeah there were a couple of people
who wanted to read it I just I want my
best work to be to reflect me and I want
to put out stuff that I want to see that
I want to see and I felt like which is
why I wrote memoirs I felt I can be
commercial but it still has to be real
and authentic and represent me and my
voice I don't just want to put anything
out there and actually I had an agent at
the time an ICM agent and she wanted me
to write more of stuff in that realm she
never saw that script but she knew about
it huh it's like can you write more and
I was like I'm never gonna write more of
that and what actually attracted her to
to me was the memoirs of a virgin
and I was like but this is why you
signed me why are you trying to get me
to write this other stuff this is why
you signed me because you liked this
script which is my voice why are you
trying to get me to write this other
stuff which is not me and
the answer was um because she thought
she could sell it
hmm so I mean and she's not a bad person
she's you know and so you know we ended
up parting ways you know you have to
make a choice sometimes and there is a
line I mean you can balance it out you
can still be commercial and real and all
that kind of stuff but there is a line
you know you have to sort of been this
that line like Juno yeah I would say
that's something that pushes the
envelope but then it's commercial
non-commercial you know because she's a
likeable character and you want to see
her win
yes and she's not you know I mean and
there's another thing I mean with
minorities you know there is I don't
even know if we call it a burden or
whatever but there is that thing where
images matter yeah how you know and you
know I feel like you do have some
responsibility for what not that there's
something for everyone but especially at
that time there wasn't enough other
stuff right be putting that out there we
needed we're trying to grow you know I
mean everyone has stereotypes you know
you know white people from Indiana has
stereotypes you know right right like
it's it's not like they don't exist and
we can't put them on film but I think
when you're a person of color or even a
woman you know to a certain degree
there's a little balance that really has
to be struck until there's enough of the
other stuff out there you know when
there's enough stuff that you can put
that other stuff where we can laugh at
it sure but when there's not enough of
that stuff then that's what people think
it is so you don't want to be
contributing to that right interesting
okay
but I did know it was commercial like
you know we don't this is Kumar so yeah
okay and I know that's what you and I
was like no but I don't like it
sure I mean and let's say for like
Legally Blonde that's definitely a
stereo
that's acceptable and but you stand
she's quirky but she's still commercial
enough where she's not that is she had a
twist because on the surface she seemed
a certain way right but we also saw that
she had a bottom and levels and she was
actually supers
right and had a soul sure but if people
only saw her as like this doll or I sort
of exactly
you